how much do you weigh bobby
oh no man 175
wow yeah it's i'm getting dia you didn't
die
i'm getting the diet yeah the beetis i
could i could feel it
i gotta change not today
not today not today another day but it's
eventually i could feel
it coming it's like you know when i was
like
when i would be on a drug binge and i
just knew
that inevitably i could see the future
right and go this is the line
and i'm getting there and so i'm getting
there with food
what is your big indulgence oh my god
take out
lately it's been just barbecue barbecue
barbecue
hot dogs hot dogs hot dogs you're
probably like me i can't
do it uh winging it i need structure
that i i told her i go i go i told her i
go get me a nutritionist oh no that's
not what you said i said can i get you a
nutritionist
what's the difference it [ __ ] use it
and i said yes
because you've got to want to do it
right yeah i want to do it i said get me
a [ __ ] nutritionist
what's the difference you i said yes to
it no i don't think you're ready he's
not ready
he's not ready the day he asks me to
call the nutritionist is when i'll
believe him okay
that's a good point that's a good point
okay i'll say this around i can't keep
offering you solutions
you gotta offer me solutions i'm gonna
give you a solution right now okay yeah
and don't get abusive go ahead i'm not
gonna okay and i'm gonna say this out
loud and this is on fact because
podcasts are
it's a fact i'm saying it out loud to
the people okay all right
next monday call me a nutritionist okay
monday got it copy i'll tell you i need
a week i'm gonna
go crazy this week though that's cool go
on your bender i'm gonna go hog wild
he's been on a two-year bench no i'm
gonna go extra
you know what i mean okay well then
you'll die before monday
yeah i may i may but if i can make it to
monday
okay right who do you replace uh bobby
with like for out of the gate
like um it's like sunday night you're
like
you reach you reach over and you're like
hey tomorrow the nutrition and he's just
like
so like like what do you how do you oh
god
and and i want to also say this whatever
you say mm-hmm
i'm not going to be offended you know if
i'm dead if i'm going for numbers or do
i want company like that's
oh that's such a good okay let's play
both okay
so who's your numbers co-host it's got
it
i love bert yeah bert's easy we have the
same
um you know dynamic great chemistry
together yep yes so
you have same hobbies hobbies like we
love the water a lot
also he talks so much so i'd have to
talk so little and i love that i do a
podcast with them i know
[Laughter]
and so it's an easy ride where you're
just like hey
all right i'll just sit here for a while
okay so there's your numbers guy
that's my numbers guy and also my yeah
um in terms of um
company a company yeah oh
god probably one of these two [ __ ]
really yeah what's sexual
sexual oh rick glass oh we're talking
about sexual or podcasting
i mean we can add sex sure okay no what
i'm what i want to know
is who you would you podcast with well
that's what we did we did
we already did that so then who who's
going to replace these are companions
but yeah that place me sexually okay as
a lover does it have to be i would
run i'm running away from this community
and industry as a whole
okay i wouldn't [ __ ] with a comedian to
make up a guy what he had but if i had
to choose a comedian if i had to
a gun wouldn't necessarily even need to
be in my head but it would absolutely be
jamar neighbors okay interesting i
love him i i find him so attractive
jamar neighbor he would hammer
that that would be my guy different yeah
no i see a lot of similarities
let's go through them no because i'm
gonna i'll be honest with jamar
neighbors is a shock to me
is it it's just he's muscular so
muscular like he's way more muscular
than i am
and he doesn't have to try it's just
there oh yeah that's a great
[ __ ] jacket he's jacked yeah he's
also um much younger
um he's weird like he is yeah he is
weird like but he's
yeah but his body yeah he you know what
it's funny
when me and jamar get neighbors get in a
room we don't know what to say to each
other yeah
we're just kind of like because we i
feel like we see each other's you know
what i mean like a mirror
like it's a mirror and also we also need
to know our defense manager
does he know this at all no no he
doesn't he's so gonna j his d
so hard to this yeah yeah
your barnard hamburgers okay all right
so
you know later today calendar is walking
down the stairs she falls down oh my
neck's broken and then you
throw her in the pool and then you need
[Laughter]
you need a podcast host co-host
a companion and a lover
okay um podcast host it has to be a
woman right
yes okay so a podcast house co-host you
gotta be regularly working with her it's
gotta be a week like someone you can do
weekly show with
i would probably do it with sarah i
would be my choice
sarah his ex my ex sarah she's lovely
also very she's crazy and i also know
her weirdness
okay nice and she's an easy
yeah i i would i would my dead self
she's married she
she you know sarah was um
a lesbian before i met her she dated me
and then she
married a woman okay so i kind of i was
like her experimental she's like
this is disgusting what if like
she just finds out she's definitely
straight but you just set her off on sun
that could be that could be all right so
sarah is your co-host now you need a
companion someone to hang out with to
hang out with
[Music]
whitney whitney is a good hang for you
yeah because
um i like whitney because um
i i don't i can't say this out loud but
um
i know her i know her game uh-huh
do you know what you mean what i'm
saying yes i do i know her game
and um so i know where she's coming from
i also know some of the sabotage and her
diabolical ways
yeah yeah i mean and her shadow play
look you don't get to where whitney got
without being
calculated savvy sophisticated
i know what you're saying and then who's
your lover now
no comedian thank god but if it had a
gun to your head
i had to i chose that's a fair that's a
fair play so hard babe
you have to oh
god i'll choose one probably an open
micro
yeah you know i mean yeah i would need
an open mic and also someone who's kind
of impressed you know like
yeah yeah i need that right right
like wow i wanted to come into this
podcast and go oh wow
yeah these two you'd be like you could
do this too one day keep at it come over
here
you know you know me wait i want to ask
you something because
you said something and i was trying to
explain this to a single woman the other
day so she was talking to me about like
dating and then she goes like well you
know something about setting me up
with setting her up with uh
a male a suitor you know a man and i was
like
i immediately go well i wouldn't set you
up with any comedians and she goes why
and i couldn't explain i was like well
because